consideration why they keep putting
dates onto these games that do not they
know full well they're not going to hit
it doesn't make any sense to me because
you just keep looking bad just don't put
a date on it you know what it is though
let's be real like they went into last
year
and people saying yo we want more
gameplay and we want dates we want game
playing we want dates and I think they
their mindset's like we don't know if
this game can realistically hit this
this this time frame that's why they
didn't give Street dates they just gave
a time period but we got to tell them
some form of time period because if they
would have came on stage last year let's
be real and gave a bunch of games with
no time frame whatsoever they would have
they would no one would have cared
anything that I've shown no if they if
they show if they show gameplay that's
excite excites me I don't really care
about the day now but people it's at its
point I think people would have been
like yo no they would have been
obliterated here's the thing people
probably would have but the issue is the
issue isn't even